[موسيقى]
هكذا يبدو مركز مدينه موسكو مستعدا
للاحتفال بعيدي الميلادي وراس السنه في
وقت تدخل فيه عمليه البلاد العسكريه
الخاصه في الاراضي الاوكرانيه شهرها
العاشر
وقال الحربي محزن للغايه او للاسف الحرب
شيئا واقع ومتكرر في الحياه التاريخ يعيد
نفسه ولا يمكن للاسف تغييره هذا
اما العاصمه الاوكرانيه فها هي شجره
الميلاد في ساحه القديسه الصوفيه تقف
مزينه تتركز على ضوء خافت من مولد يعمل
بالوقود وفترات محدوده ولاول مره بالوان
العلم الاوكراني وفي مكان نجمه الميلاد
رمز الدوله الاوكرانيه وعلى الرغم من غياب
خيام الحلوى والمشروبات الساخنه
والاحتفالات وباحات التزلجين الا ان بهجه
الاعياد حاضره رغما عنه في الحرب
الحلوه والمشروبات الساخنه لكن على اي حال
يجب ان نحافظ على روحي اعياد الميلاد لان
شبابنا المقاتلين في الجبهات يريدون ان
يواصل الناس حياتهم
في موسكو المكان والزمان يحكي اياني
مفارقه كبيره الزينه والاضواء تملان كل
ارجاء المدينه لاعاده البهجه والفرح
للمواطن الروسي في ظل الاوضاع الراهنه
خاصه ان الشريط الحدوديه للبلاد يعيش حاله
توتر وسقوط عشرات الصواريخ يوميا
اوكرانيين الذين يعتبرون اهلنا لكل روسي
اقرباء في اوكرانيا ونحن شعب واحد وهذه
حقيقه
للاستسلام تبحث عن ما يمكن ان يطفي روحها
اعياد الميلاد في المدينه فكانت الحاجه ام
الاختراع لذا ابتكرت محطه قطاراته هذه
الفكره تمام مع وضع العظام الطاقه ده
دراجه رياضيه تحول الطاقه الحركيه الى
كهرباء لتضيء شجره الميلاد التي تزين
الصاله الركاب
احساس رائع جدا انا ارى في ضوء هذه الشجره
بلادنا الحره المستقله اعياد الميلاد
تعتبر مناسبه حميمه لاجتماع الاسره حتي ان
البعض يطلق عليها تسميه العيد العائلي عدد
من الشباب يحتفل بغصه في الحلق هذه السنه
بعيدا عن جو العائله الى هرب من التعبئه
والعديد من العائلات الروسيه تستقبل عمها
الجديد خارج ديارهم التي لا طالما زقزقت
فيها شمعه راس السنه الجديده ورقصوا على
انغامي تمنياتي من حبي والسلام وبعدين
كانت شوارعها سابقا ترقص وتغني بزينه
العيد ويختلط ليلها
بمشهد الرائعه هذه هي كيف تقابل اعياد
الميلاد والاسر والاكرانيه في حاله من
الشتات فالنساء والاطفال يغادروا بلادهم
والرجال منتصرون على الجبهات والباقون
يواجهون اوضاع الانسانيه كارثه ولسان
حالهم يقول باي حال عدت يا عيد